Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in the book of purification,
the chapter regarding bathing after the
author has mentioned to us the narration
of Isa which is the centerpiece
and most comprehensive of narrations
regarding the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's manner of bathing. The author
then builds on this and he tells us that
we see that making wub before bathing
is
it is preferred and it's how the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam would most
usually make his.
However, on occasion, he would not make
wudoo before and he would just start
with putting the water onto his head,
making sure that the water gets to the
roots of his hair and pouring the
water over the entirety of his body. He
then relates a narration or cites a
narration on the authority of Muhammad.
[Silence]
Muslim. And so here we have a narration
in which
narrates that the prophet Sam
when he was asked how did the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam bathed? He said he
would take three handfuls with his hands
and pour them over his head and then he
would pour the water over the remainder
of his body. What does this mean? Three
handfuls. Remember the water is in a a
container this. Okay? and he would
put his hands inside and then pour the
water on his head and work it into his
scalp into the roots of his hair. So he
was taking the water and pouring it
three times this to make sure he
gets it. And then he would pour the
water over the remainder of his body.
What is this? This is the bare minimum
of This is the bare minimum of a person
may say, "Well, what about the mouth and
nose?" We say the mouth and nose in the
correct opinion is included in the
generality of the face and head.
Right? Because the mouth and nose
while technically inside the body, they
have the ruling of being what? outside
the body. Right? For this reason, the
prophet sallallam
says,
he said in teaching, "Take the water
deep into your nose unless you're
fasting."
Meaning, unless you're fasting, do not
take it deeply into your nose, but take
it still into your nose. Likewise, the
mouth.
[Silence]
Wasallam.
for.
[Silence]
So
here we have also that the author tells
us if a person bathes
and he is bathing for janaba
or a woman is bathing for janaba or
menration or postpartum. So these major
bathing
they are
they are bathing because they're in a
state of what? Major or minor hadith?
Major hadith. So janaba and a woman
after her
cycle after her postpartum she's in a
state of major or minor hadith. Major.
Okay. Wub is minor hadith
is major hadith. And why is it called
major hadith? Because it requires more.
And so
if a person is, listen very closely to
the words. If a person is in a state of
major hadith
and they bathe that takes the place of
wudoo.
That takes the place of why? Because
he tells us that which
alleviates
the more major includes the less major.
Meaning
But notice the caveat there. Notice the
condition. A person has to be in a state
of what? Major hadith. If a person is
not in a state of major hadith and they
bathe, does that take the place of
wudoo? No. Because they are not removing
any hadith.
Allah commands us to make wudoo if we
wish to pray. Correct? If a person said
I have so much piety,
I am so righteous that I want to bathe
instead of just regular old wudoo.
Will that
be valid for him to bathe instead of
wudoo?
They're not in a listen to the question.
Not in a state of jeneva. not in a state
of postpartum or or or cycle.
They just wish to bathe instead of make
woo. Will that will that take its place?
No.
This will not take the place of just
we have been commanded to wipe over
our head. Right? What about if I just
wash my head? Will it take the place of
wiping?
Absolutely not. Right. Just five
for will be valid or invalid.
Person says four is kind of I I can I
can spare five. I'd rather make five for
would their salah be valid or invalid?
Invalid.
Okay. So the point here is that if a
person is in a state of major hadith,
it will take the place of what? Minor
hadith. Even if they don't make wudoo.
So they pour the water over the entirety
of their body including the mouth and
nose with the intention of
they now have woo. But this is only for
a person in a state of what? major
hadith. Now Abu Omar mentions a very
important thing and that is what about
the of J does the of take the place of
now this goes back to a couple of things
first of all it's a difference of
opinion amongst the scholars however the
of J
listen closely the of J
is the of built upon it.
No,
remember we mentioned
the of is obligatory but it's not
obligatory in the way that woo is
obligatory
because wudoo is obligatory meaning it's
a condition of the salah being accepted.
But if a person does not bathe for and
they just make wudoo, is there
valid? Yes. For this reason, bathing for
in the correct opinion will not take the
place of wudoo. A person must make wudoo
unless they're in a state of janaba.
Then they can have one single intention.
And we will mention doing the same
action with multiple intentions and it
being valid is a whole other can of
worms but we will mention it inshallah
because it's very valuable. for
instance, a person walks into the masjid
before they have just made they have two
for
two for
do they have to make six or can they
just make two with with three
intentions. This is an issue we will
discuss when we get to that in the book
of salah. However,
Jum is not its validity is not
conditional.
It's not hinging on.
Therefore, the of will not take the
place of
this is different than
for because
for the person in a state of janaba,
does their hinge upon or not? Yes. So
there's a difference, right?
Subhanahu
And
[Silence]
We missed you yesterday.
[Arabic recitation]
just saying we missed you.
This will be this